[Music]
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies have
long been a topic of debate many argue
about the pros and cons of these digital
currencies the introduction of bitcoin
as legal tender fuels these discussions
even more and makes them all the more
present
although it will take some time for its
full impact to be felt bitcoin
represents a potential solution to
global poverty
or the prevailing gap between the rich
and poor
in september 2021 el salvador became the
first country in the world to adopt
bitcoin as legal tender
[Music]
the start of the new currency was
definitely bumpy the country had to deal
with various technological problems and
an additional slump in bitcoin's price
moreover people are still very
suspicious of transactions between
dollars and the tiny amounts of
cryptocurrencies
major franchise chains based in the
capital have started accepting bitcoin
via smartphone in addition the
salvadorian government introduced a
network of 200 shiva atms to familiarize
consumers with bitcoin
if president nai bokeh's plan to
introduce bitcoin is a success it is
very possible that this change will
benefit the impoverished salvadorian
economy
[Music]
government officials in el salvador
claim that the introduction of bitcoin
will increase the affordability of
services expand payment options and
increase financial innovation
success could also encourage other
countries to adopt cryptocurrencies
strengthening the possibility of
reducing poverty worldwide
nick carter of castle island ventures
was one of the first to connect with el
salvador's president via social media
he encouraged him to introduce bitcoin
as a means of payment
you hosted a historic twitter spaces
last night you started talking about
bitcoin because that's all you talk
about online and then
i think jack showed up and a bunch of
people and then the president of el
salvador showed up and you talked and
you single-handedly turned around the
coin because now it rallied today but in
your understanding and in your
conversation
uh with the president what is the main
benefit to this new law how will it in
theory help the economy and the people
of the country
well it was a fascinating time because
the president president bukayle joined
us on twitter
live as this law was being voted in
and we could actually hear the clapping
of the votes from the parliamentary
chamber
to discuss
with bighorners on twitter the merits of
the law
the objective seems to be making
using bitcoin as a actual medium of
payment medium of exchange much more
frictionless in the country eliminating
all capital gains taxes which is you
know of course a big impediment to
actually using this thing as a currency
uh you know it potentially in service of
making uh you know bitcoin based
remittances uh cheaper and less
frictional for instance so that seems to
be sort of the main thrust of the law
what can we extrapolate then uh as far
as what the future holds beyond el
salvador here do you think we'll see
other i guess legitimate countries like
el salvador embrace this in other larger
countries
well in following the salvadorian news a
number of
politicians in latin america many of
them younger on the millennial side
signaled their affinity for bitcoin as
well
and
made noises about potentially
introducing similar ideas uh we'll see
if any of that actually transpires uh we
know that bitcoin cryptocurrency stable
coins have very high penetration in
places like colombia and argentina
you know latin america is certainly no
stranger to sovereign defaults or you
know periods of high inflation or
monetary repression so we see high
penetration there there's certainly a
class of policymakers that see an
opportunity to gain favor by signaling
their affinity uh and uh you know we'll
see what happens but this is the first
el salvador is the first non-pariah
state to really legitimize and legalize
bitcoin usage uh in in sort of its
intended way uh so you know it seems
like a big sea change frankly
a big sea change that
only though
meant that we saw a seven percent rally
you're still seeing bitcoin and of
itself under pressure significantly off
the size that we saw previous in the
year nick
are you
expecting the issue for el salvador
going forward is also the ongoing
volatility within bitcoin as well is
there any point we expecting that to
just reduce a little bit so we see it
more regularly used as a currency not
just by those that are suffering
significant inflation or indeed seeing
an issue with a hard currency peg
it's hard to say bitcoin's volatility is
seen to be many as as uh you know a
natural consequence of the scarcity of
the system of course something like gold
which is you know similarly kind of a
commodity fixing issuance doesn't
evidence such significant volatility but
bitcoin is still early in its life and
uh you know very patchily adopted
globally and also in terms of el
salvador it's a very small country uh
you know
uh foreign exchange reserves in the
single digit billions um the fund that
uh president buchelli was talking about
establishing which would hold a position
in bitcoin uh he signaled they would be
in kind of the 150 million dollar range
so smaller than many kind of crypto
hedge funds uh so while this does
represent sovereign adoption it's not
sovereign adoption by the largest
sovereigns just yet uh so we'll see but
in as much as using bitcoin as a medium
of payment or bridge currency
you don't necessarily have to have
exposure to the asset for a long period
of time in order to sort of take
advantage of its its nice properties uh
nick the bitcoin community has a history
of like sort of getting excited about
certain people and then they break your
heart uh elon musk is probably the most
prominent one and ever then he's sort of
he stabbed you in the back are you
worried that uh the president won't have
a commitment to bitcoin per se and next
month it's like and now we've asked the
ethereum foundation to digitize health
records and xrp to modernize our banking
system and then it'll just be like a
bunch of crypto buzzwords in a few weeks
well what was notable about this bill
that was passed was it specifically says
bitcoin
and all of the messaging is about the
lightning network and about these
payment systems built on top of bitcoin
and there's relatively little messaging
around cryptocurrency more generally so
the commitment in this case does seem to
be regarding bitcoin of course who knows
what's going to happen in the future and
in fact there is going to be plenty of
narratives out there around bitcoin is
consorting with you know someone that is
perceived by many in the west is an
authoritarian uh dictator uh but any
adoption of bitcoin at the sovereign
level is interesting and noteworthy um
we don't shy away from that there has
been adoption of bitcoin by other
sovereigns that uh you know are
considered pariah states and nobody
tries to hide that so it's certainly
interesting to watch this play out in
real time
[Music]
in south america there have already been
several hyperinflations in the past in
venezuela for example too many new
banknotes are in circulation today
evaluating cash
unlike the wealthy people of the western
world people from developing countries
are mostly excluded from the benefits of
a higher money supply
their surplus capital is far too small
to be invested efficiently
the majority simply do not have the
ability to earn enough interest to
protect your savings
in this regard orbs reported that only
about 70 of el salvadorans are even
banked
[Music]
bitcoin can help because its supply is
finite and therefore limited
according to the bitcoin foundation
there will only ever be 21 million
bitcoins therefore when the demand for
bitcoin increases its value also
increases
the limited nature of the currency
prevents inflation helping to reduce
global poverty
unlike most national currencies central
banks cannot control bitcoin either as
it runs entirely on a decentralized
blockchain there are no transaction fees
which helps poorer people in developing
countries to increase their return on
investment without additional fees
cryptocurrencies allow even the poorest
people to make investments over which
they have full control
since cryptocurrencies prevent outside
interference in investments they create
a level playing field for everyone
that the introduction of a digital
currency can indeed have positive
effects on the stability of a country is
shown by the example of venezuela
the start of velou is helping the people
of venezuela in their fight against
hyperinflation
i'm simon chamorro i'm the co-founder
and ceo of value and we're a product
that helps venezuelans living in
hyperinflation protect their money from
losing value receive remittances and pay
locally to buy food and medicines
both businesses and consumers are able
to exchange goods and services with each
other paying in cryptocurrency
the vision for us is to increase
economic freedom
[Music]
venezuela is known for its political and
economic instability
hyperinflation has caused the bolivar to
lose 99.9 percent of its value in just
two years
wealthy venezuelan families saw their
fortunes disappear and the poor were
pushed even further into desperation
simon shomodo knows this story all too
well
growing up in venezuela essentially
whatever my dad and my mom were able to
build
during their life was lost
when the economy started to fail we for
example had water shortages or like
electricity blackouts across the country
money was starting to get hyperinflated
this is not like a sad story that i'm
trying to tell
this is the reality of most venezuelans
more than 99 of the venezuelans lost
everything they've built because the
country failed
all of the venezuelans savings of
most middle class people went to zero
i knew i wanted to build something i had
to find my purpose i always knew i
wanted to start a company and to build
things which is the reason why i studied
industrial design with the hypothesis
that i was going to be able to build
things i didn't pursue that career but i
learned a lot of things that got me into
tech so i found crypto through tech i
felt passionate about the technology and
then when i understood the potential of
crypto i realized that venezuela is
potentially the best place to do this at
a massive scale
the reality is if we deconstruct
cryptocurrencies the base most basic
thing is that it helps disintermediate
and this may have the possibility to
change society as we know it
the main problem venezuela's are going
through right now is hyperinflation
hyperinflation is just a byproduct of
total mismanagement of the country
venezuela's descent into an impoverished
dictatorship put the devastating effects
of hyperinflation on full display for
the world to see
lines for basic needs extreme shortages
of food and medical supplies
civil strife
violence and the citizens spared were
the ones who could move their currency
out of venezuela to other more stable
currencies like the us dollar a luxury
mostly saved for the ultra elite
but simon's platform value promises the
opportunity for everyday venezuelans to
protect themselves from hyperinflation
by way of cryptocurrency
and according to him the unstable
conditions of his country are the
perfect breeding ground for such an
experiment
nobody trusts the currency or the
government people are looking for
solutions in a place where people are
trying to survive the barrier of trying
new things is much lower so diesel
dollars stable coins cryptocurrencies
people are going to be willing to try it
with a little bit of money and then
slowly kind of get there
our main objective right now as a
company is to enable merchants to accept
digital dollars as a minimum of payment
and so people have to use the
bolivar less and less
we're focused on building a product that
serves from the richest person with a
lot of education and technical literacy
from the lowest in comparison with very
low education and low technical literacy
in a country like venezuela where the
minimum wage is one dollar
you have a situation where most people
are starting their own little business
selling hot dogs or selling the local
food called aleppas or whatever they do
but they sell it to their community and
you have this hyper local communities so
we want to help them accept payments in
dollars in digital dollars stablecoins
and then onboard users
the more consumers that pay in dollars
the better for the merchants the more
merchants that accept it the better for
the consumer
[Music]
so far we've moved millions of dollars
we've helped more about than 150 000
households 30 000 monthly active users
and it's working
the reality is is that economic freedom
it's only directly tackled by the
innovation that is cryptocurrencies
but we can't forget that venezuela has
tried this already el petro was a
proposed cryptocurrency backed by the
country's most abundant resource
oil while el petro was widely considered
a resounding failure many experts agree
that the experiment was a necessary step
in establishing cryptocurrency for the
future and simon is convinced that its
foundations namely blockchain technology
remain stronger than ever and ready for
another more practical iteration
blockchain is really a paradigm shift
for the human race it's one of the most
important things that has happened in
recent history
what you're starting to see
is
companies
starting to completely build their
products
on top of this blockchain it's almost
like it's creating its own economy
if there's a way to provide more
stability and economic freedom and
financial freedom to venezuelans without
crypto
i would rather for that to happen than
for me to be successful with a product
that doesn't bring value to to the
people
bitcoin operates outside the current
financial system that is there is no
central authority
since it is not yet possible for
governments and banks to interfere with
bitcoin transactions this means that
people cannot be discriminated against
when using the currency
cryptocurrencies are also very secure
and difficult to steal
which further limits potential
corruption
one problem with external aid however is
making sure that the money ends up in
the hands of those who desperately needs
it for example much of the 130 billion
that the united states has paid to
afghanistan
since 2001 has been diverted by afghan
leaders
corrupt governments that claim such aid
for themselves are particularly common
problems with several african countries
the use of bitcoin and its ability to
prevent corruption can help reduce this
problem
do you doubt that the us will make a
similar move what's your take
well i think what we've really seen now
is quite a few projects underway both in
the u.s and abroad where central banks
are beginning to explore to the
development of their own digital
currencies so we've seen that in places
like china we've seen the development of
the digital dollar project
beginning to get some traction here in
the u.s
but ultimately this is not necessarily
something that should be construed or
understood to be a competitor with
decentralized protocols like bitcoin but
rather i do see in the future that we
will see these sovereign currencies fiat
currencies do uh you know make the move
on to a you know blockchain-based system
so how is this uncertainty impacting
where you're placing your bets i mean do
you have any plans to pitch a tent on
bitcoin beach in el salvador anytime
soon
you know i think this has been a really
interesting time in the market you know
seeing moves like what we're seeing in
el salvador seeing an environment where
we have some of the world's most
followed most famous investors publicly
coming out in support of bitcoin seeing
you know major corporations begin to add
bitcoin to their balance sheets you know
this is an environment unlike we've ever
seen before around this asset class and
i certainly think the last 18 plus
months for many people in the investment
community have really solidified the
staying power that digital currencies
now have and investors are now you know
waking up to the potential
that they can provide to their
portfolios
now i just spoke with coinbase
co-founder fred ursum of the crypto
venture capital firm paradigm who's
legitimately concerned that china will
surpass the
in crypto and especially when it comes
to regulation what do you think
well i think what we're seeing here in
the u.s is a regulatory regime that has
been
very in tune with cryptocurrency and you
know certainly firms like grayscale are
a really strong example of a firm that's
working within the asset class um but
also within the existing regulatory
framework
and what you're seeing is now guidance
that has really given investors the
confidence they need to approach and be
involved in the asset class whether it's
sec cftc irs treasury fincen you name it
and what we have seen in other parts of
the world like china is a you know a
stance that i think is a little bit more
prohibitive um at times around
decentralized currencies like bitcoin so
the you know to fred's point and i and i
do sometimes agree with that that stands
that there is a little bit of you know
perhaps an arms race around this as to
which countries and which regulatory
regimes are going to be most
accommodated to the innovation that's
taking place around these types of
assets and ensuring that the companies
and the people that are using them you
know kind of get that first mover
advantage so there is some some element
of time being of the essence around some
of those initiatives
well and speaking of that we're
expecting an sec decision in the near
future on bitcoin etfs that decision was
expected this week it was pushed where
do you expect that decision to land
well you know we've been engaged with
the sec on bitcoin etfs dating all the
way back to 2016.
uh we are a hundred percent committed to
converting our flagship fund uh
grayscale bitcoin trust into an etf when
the regulatory environment is ready to
make those kinds of approvals and from
our engagement with regulators and our
seat within the financial services and
crypto communities we're really
encouraged by a lot of the progress
that's being made but i think the sec
has been very very clear that there are
certain aspects of the crypto ecosystem
that they're looking to achieve a
certain level of maturation and so
they're trying to ensure that these
markets and inherently before they
approve products around them are void of
manipulation have surveillance sharing
agreements in place in the spot market
and ultimately may have some of the same
types of investor protections in place
that they may have around equities and
other asset classes that they also
oversee
so while we're certainly making progress
you know i think clearly we're not quite
there just yet
now obviously there's been a ton of
volatility are we back on the upswing or
are we to see some more lows before we
get back to
uh
a high up cycle
well i think based on investor demand
we've seen this time and again we've
seen either leverage coming out of the
ecosystem that's caused a correction in
the price of bitcoin or other news or
other events affecting the price of
bitcoin but typically the investor
behavior has been one of using these
pullbacks in price opportunistically to
add to their positions right if they if
they fundamentally still believe in the
same investment thesis but that
investment is now available to them at
10 or maybe 15 cheaper than it was a
week or two or a month ago then
investors often use these types of
periods of time to really add to those
positions and ultimately build uh you
know a diversified portfolio you know
when you see those pullbacks
what do you think of elon musk's latest
comments i mean does the does the
whiplash bother you saying one thing
then saying another
well you're talking to someone that's
been around crypto for about eight years
now and so i've seen no shortage of
movements in in the crypto price but i
do think some of the commentary that
elon musk has made has really been
focused on esg and some of the carbon
footprint and energy consumption
concerns around bitcoin mining and i
think when it comes to that it's really
important that we stick to the facts you
know i think the latest statistic is
about 75
of miners are using renewable energy as
part of their energy mix so that could
be hydro that could be um you know wind
it could be solar and it's important to
zoom out a little bit emily and realize
we're only 10 or 12 years into the life
cycle of crypto assets and so it
definitely stands to reason that this is
an opportunity for this industry to
continue to innovate um continue to
reduce its carbon footprint um and
ultimately kind of rise to the challenge
that's being presented to it how should
we think about this then the biggest
test for bitcoin being adopted as legal
tender you know this is an exciting
moment for the for the cryptocurrency
community because of course this is what
they said will happen right i mean you
know el salvador it's it's it's it's not
you know at the center of global finance
but still this is this is the first test
for bitcoin they will be very excited
about this and you know this is um this
isn't something that has ever been done
before so just for that reason i think
this is very exciting
how much of a worry are we that this is
going to be a buy the rumor sell the
fact event el salvador only has 400
bitcoins it's not very much uh so you
know 20 20 million dollars worth um
what's the expectation from here
yeah uh i think that's that that is a
risk and there was this uh push from the
uh reddit and twitter community to say
look let's go out and buy bitcoin on you
know
on the 7th of september on today so that
they can get out there and push the
price higher but i mean we've already
seen the price rally 40
since that announcement was made so i
think there is a risk here that you know
the the the air gets let out of the
rally somewhat i do think however that
there's a lot of exciting things
happening right now in the crypto space
and one of them is also a u.s etf
potentially coming so there's just
there's there's just shy
signs that it is being adopted
more widely and i think that will be
exciting for them now paint a picture
for us eddie as to what it really means
if a country adopts this as a as their
currency because i was looking at photos
of cash points right but you go to the
cash point to change your bitcoin into
dollars so you still spend us dollars on
the street is that how this is well
it's it's a two-tier system um in in
in el salvador what they want they want
most people and big retailers to accept
bitcoin so you would be able to go there
and use your cryptocurrency wallet and
pay directly
but then also um for smaller retailers
that are not able to do so um they they
will be they will be exempt but for the
most part i think most retailers will
have to accept it it's worth noting that
it is not very popular and very popular
law um in in el salvador uh surveys have
shown that a lot of people want to see
this uh repealed but there are good
reasons for this particularly around
remittances
thank you very much eddie really good to
get your perspective on on these stories
eddie vanderbilt joining us there from
the markets live team
[Music]
bitcoin and the world of
cryptocurrencies continue to be a much
discussed topic as more and more people
around the world become interested in
their potential for people in countries
that lack financial stability
cryptocurrencies could be a viable
solution
with this ability to stop corruption
prevent discrimination
and avoid inflation bitcoin has the
potential to have a major impact on
global poverty
brock pierce chairman of the bitcoin
foundation spoke in an interview about
bitcoin's continued growth and current
problems
this is because especially for people in
rural areas it is mostly impossible to
make digital transactions even today
brock you were mentioning that you've
worked with so many other countries as
well you've spent time in el salvador
can you talk to us a little about what
you're hearing in terms of other
countries that are thinking of adopting
this by way of el salvador as well
well seeing how big a mass a massive
success this el el salvador launch has
been in terms of the impact it's having
on financial inclusion i'd say a lot of
governments are curious obviously i'm
not here to make decisions uh or advise
them per se on what to do i'm there to
give them the information so that they
can make decisions in terms of what they
think is best for their country but i'll
tell you there's a lot of interest there
is a lot of curiosity i've got i think
35 presidents in a queue right now i
literally can't move around the world
fast enough uh to give them all of the
information that they need and i'm
meeting with the the ministers the heads
of the central banks i'm meeting with uh
the business leaders the the banks the
private sector there is a great deal of
interest because of the things we talked
about and now that there is a success
and data doesn't lie
um i i think that this is going to be a
trend i think that you're going to see a
lot more adoption and acceptance from
governments around the world especially
in the emerging markets brock i'm really
curious about what you think of this
idea
of so many people are not even hacking
access to 5g internet and mobile
services i mean there's still a barrier
here to get access to bitcoin as a
currency if you don't have the
infrastructure to do that and that's a
problem here as well as in emerging
markets how do you think about that
issue when we're transforming this
economy to a digital economy
so you need connectivity it doesn't need
to be you know 5g but yes there is a
problem of connectivity around the world
it's not in cities it's typically in
rural areas because it's expensive using
land-based connections uh to reach
people where there's small populations
from a business perspective it's not
profitable now the good news is with
things like
starlink and satellite systems using air
and space we are finding mechanisms or
methods of delivering connectivity to
rural areas and we are not that far away
from everyone having access um so it's
coming
it's a separate lane in terms of major
problems in the world that need to be
solved but the good news is it is being
solved
but the launch of the world's largest
cryptocurrency got off a bumpy start in
el salvador bitcoin plunged about 17
within an hour falling to nearly 43 000
before recovering about half its losses
the bloomberg galaxy crypto index which
lists some of the largest digital coins
lost as much as 19 at times
the reason for this according to stephan
ullet managing director and co-founder
of frnt financial was mysterious
sell-offs or sell-offs for which a
legitimate reason is only found after a
considerable amount of time these are
much more common with cryptocurrencies
than with other asset classes
the crypto market remains far more
opaque and global than most if not all
other asset classes
billionaire mike novogratz chief
executive officer of galaxy digital
holdings and a longtime crypto
enthusiast said the market for digital
currency in coins in particular has been
surging and oversold over the past eight
weeks
interest from individual investors has
skyrocketed due to large institutions
now investing in cryptocurrencies
mike you are known to buy the dip so
what are you buying and how much of it
well listen i think
there's been a big sell-off today i
think we always have to remember that
crypto is still a retail
dominated uh ecosystem right we've got
institutions that are moving in by the
day and that's creating a lot of
excitement but there's lots of retail
money a lot of it's leveraged
uh there was about four billion dollars
of liquidations that happened in a short
period of time this morning right that's
mostly leveraged offshore in places like
ftx and finance
and the market got too long
it got long for good reason right i
think in the last eight weeks
there has been a giant realization that
crypto's not just bitcoin being bought
as a hedge against bad monetary and
fiscal policy but maybe more importantly
it's web 3.0 it's the internet of value
transfer
uh and when you see companies like visa
buying an nft and saying they think
digital goods is a big part of their
future
walmart and amazon the two biggest
retailers in the world putting up help
wanted science crypto engineers and for
crypto experts uh there's a realization
that this is a technology play and no
investor wants to miss the next internet
this is the next internet and so there
was a lot of great price movement right
we went from 29 000 to 53 000 and
bitcoin
you know from whatever 1800 all the way
to 4 000 in ethereum
uh solana a new
level one for most institutions has
burst on the scene and so i think we
just got too excited and this was
a little air being you know popped out
of the
balloon all right mike we do want to get
your thoughts on solana but before we
move on to that i am just curious as to
what role if any governments in will
have in this because the el salvador
approach was of course much more just
straight transactional and we've seen
sort of uh some of the concerns uh as to
sort of uh gravitating to a
transactional uh model for bitcoin and
other crypto assets here with other
governments uh decide to get into this
what role do you think they would play
in this environment
there's there's two different sides to
this right governments are going to be
very very protective of their national
currencies right their ability to to tax
and credit currencies
uh is
is is pan amount to them existing lots
of plates and so
i think they'll be okay with payments
you're going to see the rise of stable
coins right china's issuing one you'll
see them in almost every major country
uh you know basically wrapped versions
of those national currencies
um and i think things like bitcoin which
in the west really are being used to
store value people aren't using it as a
transaction currency i think what's
unique in el salvador is you know 20 of
their gdp comes from reminiscence
and so
you can see lots of those remittances
people sending
bitcoin back across
oceans from the u.s to el salvador and
the locals either keeping bitcoin
because they're worried about the dollar
remember they have a dollarized economy
or
converting it and spending it uh
in the local economy and so you know
it's they're kind of unique in that
respect and we'll see you know maybe it
gets used as a transactional currency
i've never thought it would be partly
because i think it's going to keep going
higher and why would you spend something
that's going to keep going higher
well could you argue though why would
you spend on something on days like
today where 10 minutes later it drops 10
percent you know could you make the case
that
like you were hinting that taylor if
you're such a good trader you know what
time to buy the pizza
i'm paying bitcoin in dollars i
shouldn't hire you
it's really difficult to understand in
the short term where markets are going
yeah um
in the longer term it's not so difficult
just look at a 15 year or 12 year long
chart of the bitcoin price and think
about the adoption that is happening all
over the world
um
you know it is now an asset it's a store
of value i i like to kid when stan
druckenmiller said it was an asset he's
literally the best investor we've seen
in 30 years it's an asset
and so there are enough stan
druckenmiller is there enough
institutions that have said they believe
in this as a store of value that it is a
store event mike right i just see it
heading one direction the rollout today
for el salvador is choppy there's a
price drop there was technology glitches
at the beginning a big go which you've
agreed to buy is a company that is
working with el salvador
what do you make of today's rollout and
what impact might it have on future
countries that may choose to go this
route venezuela for example comes to
mind when a lot of people talk about
this
listen no matter whatever you're doing a
new technology roll out their glitches
and so i guess the real question is come
back in six weeks uh are 12 weeks and
let's talk about how it's working you
know for the people of el salvador for
the system itself
um
you know i remember when obama
rolled out obamacare it was kind of a
disaster for a little while and they
they they sorted the glitches out you
know doing things at scale is not easy
and so i've got a lot of faith that uh
they'll get this right you know the
other thing is that we're in a place
where you see these young traders moving
to the market uh across the world and
you see them buying nfts you see them
buying mean stops for the last few few
months what's the next big thing that
you think that the retail trader could
catch on to
great question listen i think what the
lesson that we should learn from this
year is that
there are so many eyeballs out there
right and the faster you can see
something that catches those eyeballs
and builds community the faster the
price moves and so it literally is
watching for what the next idea is
um
and then those communities become much
stronger than i ever thought
right i used to think okay bitcoin will
work and and the
the cryptos that get a lot of use like
ethereum things building on it or even
solana lots of people are now building
on it would work but some of these other
things wouldn't they wouldn't have a
purpose and i've just been wrong right
you look at cardano or xrp they have
these fan clubs these very
uh
committed
uh investors who are bringing people in
their community and really it's a sense
of identity and so i think what we're
learning is the internet
uh and retail interest
has created almost a new way to think of
investing it's can they build a
community can they make it sustainable
with you know bringing more people in
when money's cheap and there's so much
money floating around we're seeing
you know things that i never thought
would happen i mean gamestop amc perfect
examples
of stocks that now don't that trade
completely divorced from the
fundamentals of the company
um and you're seeing that same thing in
crypto
so
when we talk about sort of the way some
investors gravitate to things mike i
mean you mentioned solana a couple times
here we talk about uh the the token uh
sort of tied to that and just how fast
it sort of uh sort of vaulted itself
into sort of public consciousness here
i'm curious as to what you think is
driving that and about the
sustainability of some of these moves
here because that always seems to be the
question people have particularly people
new to this they sort of look at the
volatility and they wonder
where is this sustainable well look you
look at you know
sam bankman free who runs ftx is 30
years old and just raised 900 million
dollars for his company an 18 billion
dollar evaluation from some of the best
investors in the world right he's a
legend in this space and he's the backer
of solana
and so that's his ecosystem so people
are betting on sam
uh as more people come in
they get excited right institutions are
coming in
um and it hit a it hit a critical point
of acceleration where now it's a thing
what's a blockchain a blockchain is a
database that we all share solana is
exciting because it's easier to build on
because it's really fast
right it's faster than ethereum it's
faster because it's not nearly as
decentralized it's not nearly as secure
and safe in some ways right there's only
you know
uh
a couple dozen
validators
of the solana blockchain where there's
thousands on the ethereum watching
um right now consumers don't seem to
care
right it's decentralized enough and
regulators don't seem to care there is a
fair question will in time regulators
say we're not going to let
this business infrastructure
for our country of the world be built on
blockchains that aren't decentralized
like that's up for grabs you know that's
that's that's really in the weeds uh
right now that's not what the market's
focused on the market's both focused on
fast and better
and can they get people to build on it
and is there excitement around it and so
you know luna luna is another blockchain
and i have big investments in full
disclosure uh juan from korea he's like
the sam bankman free he's pulling all
kinds of products and projects into his
ecosystem mike unfortunately i have to
be sort of the boring one that brings us
back to macro i am wondering your call
on rates are you still short you betting
rates to climb from here
i am short rates listen you know they've
had a decent little move recently uh you
know rates higher prices lower
i just think
it's it's impossible to own as much
crypto as i do or other assets equities
and not want to have a big rate short
um there is a possibility that inflation
is much stickier than we think and
accelerates and that the fed will have
to
to move sooner than they think and more
aggressive when they move um
they might not if they don't i think
assets keep going up for a long period
of time right as long as pal keeps easy
money you can stay long your assets but
it feels like it's a it's a really
important hedge for any portfolio that's
acid
while the launch in el salvador may have
been a possible cause of the
fluctuations in bitcoin other variables
in the notoriously volatile crypto
sector may also be at play the central
americans country's president naive
buchelli shared on twitter that the
digital wallet used for the project can
now be downloaded after previously being
shut down due to technical issues
kivo is a bitcoin wallet that allows
salvadorian citizens and businesses to
send or receive payments in bitcoin or
dollars anywhere in the world
with kivo bitcoins can be automatically
converted into us dollars
also people in el salvador can use it to
withdraw bitcoin holdings or cash at
bitcoin atms
el salvador has used the us dollar as
its national currency since 2001 when it
switched from the colon currency which
has issued in 1982. the main service
provider of the kiva wallet is
reportedly mexico based exchange bitso
which is one of the largest
cryptocurrency exchanges in latin
america
bitso is working with the u.s federal
reserve member silvergate to facilitate
u.s dollar transactions for the wallet
emily chang was in conversation with
falcon access anya kotorvich and
bloomberg news's michael mcdonald to
discuss first impressions of the bitcoin
rollout in el salvador
what does this mean for bitcoin what
does this mean for el salvador
yeah well um you know as you mentioned
today it became legal tender in el
salvador so uh what it means for bitcoin
is um there are businesses in el
salvador that will be required to accept
this if they're technologically able um
we've seen several businesses today
start to accept it in el salvador a lot
of the larger ones mcdonald's pizza hut
starbucks we've seen transactions in
bitcoin go through with some of these
larger chains in el salvador um also
citizens in el salvador if they want
they can pay their taxes in bitcoin as
well so um you know it did become legal
tender it is going to operate alongside
the dollar for now in el salvador's uh
so the dollar will still be a national
currency there as well so if people
don't want to use bitcoin they can use
the dollar as well
but uh businesses will be required to
accept it if they are technologically
able as of today
that said with the president saying to
buy the dip the technical glitches aya
um
should we be at all skeptical of what's
happening here
yeah that's a good question i think uh
you know it will take time i agree with
what mike novogratz said that this is
going to take a lot of time
infrastructure in order to accept these
payments at scale uh will take a
significant manpower uh and time and
investment as well and i think uh while
you know they're putting into place uh
thousands of atms uh the payment
processors in all of these different
businesses uh will take time but i think
for a country you know taking a step
back from what michael said even around
some of those larger companies for a
country where a quarter of their gdp uh
is based on remittances i think this is
much larger uh in terms of the impact it
can have on the population and their
ability to uh you know move money across
borders that perhaps they can't today
but could if they just had a mobile
device
that said the population isn't
necessarily too excited about it michael
i've seen polls that show a lot of
distrust
among folks who live in the country how
widespread is that and could that really
slow down broader adoption
sure yeah we've seen polls in the weeks
leading up to this
that about 70 percent of el salvadorans
prefer to use the dollar
to bitcoin and we've also seen that
about 70 have said that they would like
to see this bitcoin law um repealed so
there is quite a bit of skepticism of it
on the ground i also think there's a
pretty large financial education
learning curve um you know el salvador
is is not a country that has a lot of
its citizens using the traditional
banking system uh it's it's you know
cash is still king in el salvador um so
you know when you bring in this sort of
new
technology like cryptocurrency uh you
know there is sort of a hesitancy and
there is uh sort of some pushback at
first um so you know we are seeing um
a lot of people that are skeptical on
the ground there were a lot of questions
this morning with the chivo wallet
people couldn't download it it was
offline for a little while so the
government could fix some glitches so it
was a little bit of a rocky start and
there is there is some skepticism in el
salvador
that said aya we've learned that we can
never judge bitcoin on any any given day
but what do you make of what's behind
this price move how much does this have
to do with el salvador or is it
something else
yeah good question so it had nothing to
do uh really with el salvador what we
saw today was very much what we saw
historically with
bit max liquidations and so you're
seeing uh over the last couple of weeks
a lot of whether it's retail and
institution on overseas exchanges pile
into derivatives products for futures
in products that maybe they didn't
necessarily know or were funding
correctly uh and there was a leverage
waterfall and so cascading liquidations
happened uh this morning now what i
would
really really interesting uh is that
this was very much like a a
bare day and so we saw that bounce back
really quickly so as was discussed
earlier we dropped down to 44 we're now
at a support level of 47.
i still think we're very much nearing
that 60k mark and so we're continuing to
see a lot of i think of the 2.6 billion
uh in liquidations 1.1 billion was in
bitcoin 700 million was in ethereum and
this was
largely driven by ethereum and d5 assets
uh so it's still very bullish on
long-term view uh for price on bitcoin
if you you're that uh optimistic when do
we get to 60k and also we've had the
co-founder of of kraken on the show who
say we're going to get to 100 before the
end of the year would you agree
yes i
may not agree with with jesse on that uh
he's he's very bullish but uh you know
that's a that's a good question i think
we'll see it in the next couple of weeks
really the what pushed us beyond 50k
wasn't uh the leverage on bitcoin there
was people uh you know accumulating
bitcoin at spot and buying it in size
and what we were seeing at falcon x at
least today is a lot of these
institutions took the opportunity to buy
the dip
at not only bitcoin but across different
assets and so i think we'll we'll see
that 60k uh sooner than we expect i
think in the next couple weeks
the probe bitcoin government under
president bukit announced that his
country will respond to the recent price
drop by buying 150 more coins at an
average price of just over forty eight
thousand and five hundred dollars
it is safe to say that el salvador is
one of the countries that is very
positive towards bitcoin as it has
summarily legalized the primary
cryptocurrency since then the president
naive buckingham and his government has
taken over every opportunity to further
capitalize on opportunities in the
market such as the plan to use btc
profits to build schools and a
veterinary clinic
just recently achilles announced plans
to build a bitcoin city and invest an
additional 500 million in the value of
security through a special bond
off to a little bit of a rocky start as
the price on bitcoin itself crashed and
the co and the country of course had a
little bit of trouble rolling out that
payment system joining us right now to
talk a little bit more about this is
bitcoin enthusiast joe weisenthal who of
course has been following uh this
rollout for us joe obviously you do a
lot more than that but you certainly
know a lot uh not only about bitcoin
about about this whole ecosystem here
i'm just curious as to
what you generally expected from the
start of a country even though it's a
small country using this as legal tender
you know it's hard for me to imagine
that the existence of another currency
will itself amount to this big
transformation but it would not surprise
me if at the margins or maybe to his uh
substantial degree it does bring in
foreign direct investment obviously a
lot of actual bitcoin enthusiasts
investors technologists in the space are
very excited about what's going on there
and so the idea that perhaps they could
set up shop
uh in the country is uh miners
developers and so forth uh perhaps also
uh bitcoin tourism it would not be uh
surprising if one effect is to
essentially bring in uh more outside
capital
we know you know obviously one of the
most important things here will be for
other countries thinking about this joe
some of the learning that happens here
what are you watching most closely what
do you think will be most interesting
about how this works and who uses it and
what the challenges are
well i think it'll be really interesting
to see uh you know a few things one is
do people use it as a spending currency
or you know most people in the u.s and
develop markets who uh own bitcoin
mostly own it as an investment so
that'll be interesting um there's also
interesting technological questions the
degree to which uh people find it easy
to use uh the various solutions that are
being developed whether it's the
government's wallet or another wallet
that'll be really interesting to watch
because that might inform whether other
countries uh try to adopt something
similar so i guess just usage patterns
in general what apps and how whether
it's spending uh investment those are
all interesting things to track
i want to bring in nick carter a partner
at castle island ventures nick hosted a
chat on social with the president of el
salvador encouraging him to adopt
bitcoin not long before the country did
exactly that um so nick uh we won't say
that it was your brainchild but
certainly you were part of the
conversation with the leadership there
what are you watching most closely here
now that they have taken this step
well i'm curious to see the extent to
which
second layer networks like the lightning
network actually get utilization
apparently it looks like the official
chivo app will support this overlay
network
and so i'm very curious
as joe says as well to see whether
salvadorans actually embrace
uh bitcoin as a medium of exchange um so
far the evidence is that salvadorans are
mostly
bemused about the move uh but you know
it'll be very interesting to see if they
actually use it at merchants well that's
what i'm curious about nick i mean
obviously there's the bitcoin faithful
and then you have some institutions that
see the investment opportunity uh within
it but of course trying to convince just
average people on the ground to use this
in a transactional way it has to be a
bit of a hard sell and we've seen some
data showing uh polling out of el
salvador saying something like 70 of the
public doesn't really want this thing
how do you overcome that how does this
country sort of mount that type of
public perception and opposition to
something that they seem to be tethering
their future to
well i'd be surprised if
bitcoin became the dominant medium of
exchange in the country i expect dollars
to be
the predominant solution for the
foreseeable future
um it is a little bit
uh surprising that the bu kelly
administration has pushed bitcoin as a
medium of exchange uh so firmly
uh when at the sovereign level it seems
like the most obvious thing to do would
be to adopt it you know in their foreign
exchange reserves uh as kind of a
gold-like analog
um whereas
at the brick and mortar merchant level
bitcoin is not a popular tool nor has it
really ever been uh so it's a little bit
surprising to me to see their emphasis
uh in sort of you know that
transactional mode
nick what do you see is the upside
scenario here for so obviously look a
lot of bitcoiners such as yourself have
been very enthusiastic very excited
about this news
what does success look like either for
bitcoin or more importantly what do you
think if uh you know success could mean
for el salvador
well for el salvador they're going to
have to normalize their relations with
the international institutions like the
imf there's a lot of uncertainty that
they're they need to resolve
investors in salvador and debt are
pretty concerned
and so i'd like to see
yields come down a little bit
but
generally speaking i think a relatively
smooth rollout the chivo wallet appears
to be working it's in the app store so
um sort of in theory it works um
it would be
i think damaging to the effort if the
bouquet administration started to
enforce article 7 in the law really
aggressively uh against merchants that
didn't offer bitcoin
um you know transaction settlement um so
as currently conceived this law is
actually more of a force tender than a
legal tender law and actually mandates
merchant acceptance if they start to
enforce that really aggressively i think
that would be a pretty significant
optics blow
for the buchelle administration it might
trickle down the bitcoin as well
nick obviously there will be a lot of
kind of process learning here but in
terms of sort of the argument for the
possibility uh
it's there what would you expect to see
larger countries uh more kind of
globally integrated countries adopting
bitcoin in the same way anytime soon
perhaps not embracing it as this medium
exchange
which as i've said is is you know a
curious approach
but as a
sort of non-sovereign
digital gold like asset that you can
hold
and use to diversify your exposure away
from sovereign currencies like the
dollar to me that seems like the most
obvious approach
el salvador to be clear is probably not
the first sovereign state to hold
bitcoin at you know on its balance sheet
uh it's certainly rumored and quite
plausible that states like iran uh
venezuela or north korea all hold
bitcoin in some capacity they're the
first ones to do it explicitly though um
but yeah as as bitcoin becomes more of
this gold-like asset and
you know fully undertakes that process
of maturity and financialization uh
that's where i'd expect to see uptake um
you know as central banks potentially
look for this sort of non-sovereign uh
you know asset that they can hold
but just to be clear nick so when you
talk about uptake you're talking about
uh these central banks sort of building
that up in its reserve of the treasury
uh in its reserves to a level that i
guess would maybe by default just sort
of force uptake
uh yeah that's what i would expect to
see in terms of sovereign adoption of
bitcoin um none of us really expected
that the first nation to fully embrace
bitcoin would do it in terms of
encouraging it to become a dominant
medium exchange
uh so you think do you think there's
going to be another country i mean
actually more importantly like bitcoin
hasn't gone anywhere in a long time
price wise it went down quite a bit
since the highs earlier in the spring
then it's bounced back like what is the
next big catalyst you're watching for
was it more on the national side is it
something on an etf like what do you
think is going to be the next thing that
gets people excited about bitcoin
because even with the recent crypto
rally it seems like people are really
more excited about like solana or like
buying a jpeg of an ape
well you have to consider in context and
i think it's those macroeconomic drivers
that are really going to determine the
next few years of bitcoin's
future effectively uh if we get this
kind of sustained uh monetary repression
with
negative real interest rates i think
assets like bitcoin continue to look
attractive to investors bitcoin itself
doesn't really have to change much um
it's sort of quite well understood and
of course there's things like an etf
which would be uh you know further
financialization make it suitable for
other market participants to get
exposure to but that's pretty
incremental at this point i think it
really just depends what's happening out
there on sort of the broader
macroeconomic environment
we know that there is a you know plenty
of review happening at the sec and
elsewhere from a regulatory point of
view about cryptos in general uh and
their use and their applications uh
what do you think where do you think we
are and how does this if in any way
change the thinking by the sec for
instance in the legitimacy of these
products and how they will be used by
perhaps even the federal reserve
well
uh scc chairman genzler understands
bitcoin very well
and i think his opinion of it is sort of
fully uh complete and he's you know i
think carved it out uh as you know
something that's truly decentralized uh
he's made statements that effect uh now
the remainder of the crypto space
especially decentralized finance on some
of these you know crypto banks lenders
seem to be in his crosshairs uh i think
the sec
is a more activist icc it's uh more it's
just fundamentally more active than the
prior sec
and has a number of sort of litigations
undergoing including with ripple um and
gensler has made some you know pretty
direct and aggressive statements about
the decentralized finance space and i
think the whole industry is kind of
expecting some sort of reprisal there
although we don't we don't know exactly
what form it's going to take yet would a
reprisal towards decentralized finance
be bad for bitcoin because it would say
oh all of crypto
is on in the crosshairs or would it be
good in the sense that
non-bitcoin crypto is largely viewed as
a uh regulatory arbitrage play that then
gets stamped out
it's a great question because bitcoin is
not the dominant collateral type in
decentralized finance although it is
somewhat involved um any reprisals might
concern platforms or exchanges where of
course bitcoin trades as well and it
might affect the liquidity profile but
it's a good point bitcoin is somewhat
distinct from the broader decentralized
finance movement
that said i think
you know investor pessimism would
percolate throughout the whole industry
and probably adversely affect bitcoin at
the same time
[Music]
currently we are experiencing a severe
correction on the crypto market bitcoin
is also clearly feeling this
but bitcoin's current plunge is dwarfed
by the sharp trading losses the collapse
of el salvador's bonds which has driven
up el salvador's financing cost the
country's foreign bonds posted the
world's worst performance in 2021 as
investors were spooked by brachialis
unorthodox economic management in the
bitcoin experiment
[Music]
extended fund financing with the help of
the international monetary fund has not
materialized due to multilateral lenders
concerns about bitcoin
bouquet has become a celebrity in a
bitcoin community for buying on price
drops and promising to build a tax-free
bitcoin city on the country's coast
what do analysts think of this buying
the dip strategy by the president
hey charlie i want to start with you
because you wrote about retail traders
buying the dip is there patience with
bitcoin volatility
is it wearing a little bit thin
well with some of them so anytime you
see bitcoin or other you know me me
assets start to decline you see this
barrage of tweets of facebook posts of
reddit posts saying quote unquote buy
the dip and a lot of retail investors by
this point in the year have bought some
of these dips but they've only seen dips
continue and they've lost money so with
a number of the people that i spoke with
including a woman who lost about two
thousand dollars buying a dip that kept
dipping um yes there is you know a loss
of patience here
and so valdona let's talk about exactly
what happened yesterday because i was
off but it seemed like it was really bad
and i noticed in your story you had a
detail in there that some 3.7 billion
dollars of crypto liquidations occurred
in 24 hours what does that mean were
people basically being forced out of
their positions
yeah so the decline yesterday was really
precipitous it was so incredibly quick i
think a lot of people had been watching
the charts and and maybe guessing the
bitcoin was going to hit 50 000
yesterday and cross above it and then in
a matter of minutes you saw it just
decline it wiped out 10 then 15 then 17
so certainly you had some people who
maybe aren't hodlers meaning they're not
holding on for dear life and maybe
potentially they got scared and some of
them sold out of their positions but at
the same time you had had these really
interesting statistics about these
liquidations basically what happens is
somebody can borrow money and make bets
on cryptocurrencies and when those bets
go wrong your positions can actually get
liquidated so i was looking at data from
this company called buy bit they track
some of these trends and so they saw
that some
330 000 of these traders were liquidated
yesterday not amounted to more than
three and a half billion dollars worth
of cryptocurrencies in yesterday's
sell-off so huge numbers really
precipitous decline and you have sort of
a lot of these things at play but
certainly these liquidations were a big
part of yesterday's decline well what's
so interesting valdona and charlie is it
came on the day that el salvador adopted
bitcoin as legal tender so charlie i
know you were watching this closely
because this was a very big test for the
idea of this being a well cryptocurrency
or at least legal tender in a country
what did you learn about the the roll
out the implementation of it and and
what that had to do with yesterday's
decline was there any relationship with
the sell-off that we saw there and what
happened in el salvador
yeah so the tweets really tell the story
here so this was billed as one of the
biggest tests for bitcoin that you know
a country albeit small was going to
start accepting bitcoin as legal tender
the president was touting this there was
you know quite widespread opposition but
this was seen as a test um for bitcoin
as a currency that could be accepted in
you know uh retailers and so before this
happened a number of bitcoin supporters
across social media talked about how
they wanted to try to boost this in a
sort of memey way people were buying 30
worth of bitcoin which is the amount of
money that people in el salvador were
going to be given um and this was you
know hoping to to support uh this
rollout there were technical issues that
we saw very quickly and a lot of
disappointment and so you know
potential causation or at least
correlation there um connected to the
drop yesterday and what people were
seeing in el salvador
[Music]
el salvador is thus the first country in
the world to adopt bitcoin as a legal
currency
the country has been using the us dollar
for more than 20 years and continues its
bitcoin friendly course in 2022. the
government has once again injected
several million dollars into the
controversial cryptocurrency
likewise el salvador is planning to
build bitcoin city the world's first
bitcoin city
bitcoin city is to be built in the
eastern area of la union president nai
bukili recently announced it will be
powered by a nearby volcano kukili said
the planned city will be financed with
bonds that are also tied to virtual
currencies
the announcement was made during an
event at the country's week long latin
american bitcoin and blockchain
conference
samsung mao who attended the event along
with wakili said in addition el salvador
plans to issue 1 billion worth of
bitcoin bonds in 2022.
ma is an executive at blockstream a
blockchain technology provider
once funding is in place construction of
bitcoin city could begin within 60 days
buchilli said
maul added that the city could make el
salvador the financial center of the
world the government said it will
provide land infrastructure and low
taxes to attract investors
quickly said there will be no poverty
income or municipal taxes only
value-added tax
the government also already operate a
bitcoin mining test project it is
located near another geothermal area
next to the tikkapa volcano in the
eastern part of the country
the government plans to use about half
of the tax revenue to fund bitcoin city
the other half will be used for local
services okay estimated that the public
infrastructure projects will cost about
300 000 bitcoins
the government currency supports bitcoin
with a 150 million fund to encourage
salvadorans to use bitcoin the
government offer a 30 credit with the
use of digital wallets
bitcoin was originally created to
operate outside of government control
financial systems whether
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin can really
solve major problems of our current
financial system remains to be seen
el salvador has dared to take the step
into the future will other countries
follow suit
foreign